y con directo a nos vamos hoy hasta
Washington la capital estadounidense
para conversar con nuestro corresponsal
Cristóbal Vázquez sobre la nueva subida
de los tipos de interés por parte de la
reserva Federal en esta ocasión el
aumento fue de 0,25 puntos porcentuales
una cifra bastante menor a las
anteriores lo que desató el rumor de un
posible cese de las subidas el
presidente de la Fed jeron Powell negó
esta posibilidad Cristóbal que supone
esta nueva Aunque más relajada su vida y
que ha dicho Powell sobre los siguientes
pasos quedará la reserva Federal
lo que dicen muchos analistas en cuanto
a esta subida pequeña de 25 puntos
porcentuales de puntos básicos perdón de
las tasas de interés es que Posiblemente
sea la última subida en esta Ronda de
alzas de tasas de interés que viene
siendo el Banco Central estadounidense
La Ronda de alza de tasas más agresiva
desde
1980 lo que te están diciendo y lo que
de alguna manera dice el lenguaje de la
reserva Federal Y a partir de la rueda
de prensa de John Powell es que quieren
esperar a ver si efectivamente esta tasa
de interés que quedan cinco punto
veinticinco por ciento va a ser
suficiente para mitigar la inflación la
inflación que ha venido reduciéndose en
los últimos meses acá en Estados Unidos
entonces quieren esperar poner ese freno
mitigar esa alza que esa alza que viene
desde hace meses para ver si
efectivamente se logra esa mitigación en
la inflación en Estados Unidos y al
mismo tiempo tratar que dado estas altas
tasas de interés que hay en Estados
Unidos mitigar al mismo tiempo los
efectos que tiene en el repago de las
deudas de los bancos en Estados Unidos
eh dado estas altas tasas de interés en
esta rueda de prensa lleva un Power
también resaltó que es muy importante
que Próximamente el congreso se ponga de
acuerdo para aprobar una alza en el
límite de la deuda de Estados Unidos
porque de no hacerlo tendría
consecuencias económicas y financieras
gravísimas para Estados Unidos entre
otras pues entrar en default en su pago
de su
de por otro lado además Cristóbal el
Banco Mundial confirmó al estadounidense
de origen indio Ay ay ay ranga manga
perdón como su nuevo presidente Qué
significa para el organismo que salga de
bitmalpa es un estrecho Aliado de Donald
Trump y en su lugar que del candidato de
Joe biden
sí aunque el Banco Mundial el grupo
Banco Mundial es un organismo bastante
grande bastante burocrático que salga
malpaz que en su pasado además no
reconocía O no le daba la importancia
suficiente a la crisis climática
significa entonces que ahora el Banco
Mundial va a estar mucho más acorde
mucho más afín a esta lucha contra el
cambio climático financiando apoyando
iniciativas pues es mucho más fuertes
para el litigamiento de esta crisis
climática va a significar también pues
ayuda a países que más necesitan en el
hemisferio sur precisamente porque
muchos de estos países
en desarrollo están siendo Víctimas de
muchos efectos del cambio climático
entonces significaría posiblemente esta
ayuda un poco más significativa a estos
a estos países también significará
obviamente políticas macroeconómicas y
políticas económicas más afín al
gobierno de Jo e biden Estados Unidos
que al fin de cuentas es el país que más
poder tiene el Banco Mundial hay que
Resaltar que de facto el presidente del
Banco Mundial lo elige Estados Unidos el
presidente del fondo monetario
internacional lo elige Europa y del
banco interamericano de desarrollo queda
en el poder normalmente un
latinoamericano